the buddy guys still our guest today is
Michelle udas an expert on Islam and
terrorism welcome welcome to the DW
interview I'm Tomas spawn what was your
first reaction to the terrorist attack
in nice-nice john vedoe I thought not
again France has already suffered
several attacks so have cities like
Brussels and Istanbul and countries in
the Middle East 300 people were killed
earlier this month in Baghdad people
want us to stop but realistically I'm
afraid it's just the beginning this will
continue for the next few years but
there was a state of emergency in France
the time can't we do anything not
against these kinds of attacks there's
nothing the police or other authorities
can do if an individual decides to blow
himself up or to kill people in some
other way you can't stop it it is
possible to prevent 9/11 style attacks
but it's very difficult to stop
so-called lone wolf attacks where the
perpetrator is unknown to police or has
no connection to political violence is
and other terrorist organizations have
been recruiting supporters in the
immigrant communities in French slums
but France has long had problems trying
to integrate immigrants why is friends
suddenly being hit by attacks now Thomas
Monson helps to look at the background
of the attackers when we ask how did
they become radicalized we find that
first and foremost they had a troubled
past Islam and Islamism played the
subordinate role the young people who go
off to fight in Syria or are drawn to
the radical ideologies often didn't get
along with their parents
and they feel like losers will never
achieve anything the bonds in Satara
Brent Ponte for decades France has
neglected these slum neighborhood the
government can't provide these people
with opportunities to make something of
their lives the haves and have-nots are
socially segregated in France and now
the third generation is growing up in
these slums many of them are thinking
this country has nothing to offer me I
don't want to be part of this society
I'm declaring war in this country and
that's easy to do these days because is
offers them an ideology and an
organization Chancellor Merkel says
Germany will stand by France in the
fight against terrorism
yes it's estimate by France will
appreciate that Germany and France are
the most important allies in the EU
particularly since the breaks it so
Germany will always support France
Germany has sent troops to the West
African state of Mali a former French
colony even though Germany has no
national interests there still there's
not much that Germany its government or
its people can do to help directly first
of all this is a domestic French problem
and they'll have to do so what causes
this terrorism I think it's partially
the result of the West's policy of
intervening in North Africa and the
Middle East and toppling regimes this
has led to the collapse of entire states
it's caused anarchy and Islamic
militants and is have filled the void
meanwhile there's a growing perception
in the German government that military
intervention is an option and that's
unfortunate for example Germany is
considering getting involved in Libya
Germany isn't part of the campaign
against is in Iraq and Syria is this a
clever move that avoids us being
targeted by is
I don't think that's particularly
important for is Germany we'll get more
involved think of the government's new
report on security policy obviously the
German government believes that the
military can be deployed as part of a
Coalition of the Willing regardless of
international law this applies
especially to Libya it's become the
primary transit country for refugees
trying to reach Europe
now that the Balkan route has been
blocked and so now borders are being
closed to try to stop those people Libya
has been torn by anarchy and chaos
ever since Gaddafi was talk about 2011
you mentioned refugees we have 1 million
of them in Germany mostly from Arab
countries will I ass be able to recruit
some of Florida's phylum I think that is
Appeals primarily to the millions in the
Middle East who have no future of course
we can't rule out that there will be
potential terrorists among the refugees
but I haven't seen any reliable evidence
that suggests that this is a major risk
we should take a calm and rational
approach not every refugee is a
potential terrorist we shouldn't forget
that most of the refugees from Syria are
fleeing a war zone could there be
troublemakers among them of course we
can't rule that out that's part of the
risk like terrorism itself and we just
have to deal with it it's becoming
increasingly likely that Germany will be
attacked is it just a matter of time the
German authorities agreed that we've
been lucky so far because we've had no
major attacks but it could happen at any
moment like I said the situation in
Germany is somewhat different we have
different patterns of immigration we
have
no french-style immigrant slums we don't
have no-go areas although things appear
to be moving in that direction in some
parts of the region
in any case an attack could occur at any
time in Berlin Munich Gilla film
wherever and unfortunately we simply
have to learn to accept that you say
that the West's fight against terrorism
as radicalized more people and produced
more terrorism so how can we fight is
effectively missing me mr. Tony Seeman
unfun we should learn from our mistakes
and admit that these interventions were
failures this view is not shared by many
politicians today instead many explain
the rise of the highest by citing the
Quran that's nonsense of my opinion I
believe is is the product of the West's
misguided foreign policy and incompetent
Arab regimes that were never interested
in bringing democracy into their
societies that is its own yet so it'll
take years if not decades to end this
turmoil there is no easy solution the
West and Germany in particular it likes
to come up with solutions what needs to
be done step one step two step three man
by next spring the worst will be
overnight but it won't be that simple we
have to get used to the chaos and arcane
violence even though all that plays into
the hands of right-wing populist and
radicals I fear that at some point
right-wing radicals and jihadis will be
fighting each other in the streets here
in Europe when moment on a plan is
doesn't seem to have any trouble finding
recruits are these young people simply
drawn to violence slow versus firing
perspective foolish party all right
that young people who have no chance to
make something of their lives don't have
a lot of alternatives if they live in
Syria or Iraq countries torn by Civil
War few will have the opportunity to get
an education and a job is is attractive
to these people because it offers them
employment millions of people including
hundreds of thousands of young people
lead dismal lives in refugee camps is
has begun recruiting young refugees from
camps in Turkey Lebanon and Jordan
there are even jihadist schools some
parents send their kids to these schools
because they have no money you have no
other choice in the continent iva theta
many of those who've committed terrorist
attacks grew up in Europe and at few or
no ties to terrorist networks maybe they
don't need those connections they just
act on their own yes in a way they are
unpredictable so it's a mistake to
believe that by launching airstrikes on
Raqqa the de facto capital of ISIL we
can solve problems in Europe
that's how France reacted after the
attacks last November
but that won't solve anything we have to
acknowledge that terrorism is a domestic
problem we need to ask ourselves how all
this happened and what can be done to
prevent it I think moderate Muslims are
currently having a hard time dealing
with this right now they're not sure how
to position themselves on Islam and
terrorism they don't want to constantly
speak out against something that they
have no responsibility for but I do
think that moderate middle-class Muslims
and middle-class non-muslims will have
to speak out and say that they want to
live together in peace and that they
reject terrorism
I know gesellschaft leaf religious don't
think about it or Skansen that's about
it that will take a long time so we'll
just have to get used to living with
terrorism how will that change our lives
there will be a lot of insecurity people
myself included will suppress their fear
of terrorism people have to get on with
their lives after all
terrorism is a potential risk just like
traffic accidents they can occur at any
time we'll simply have to take that into
account and that could have a calming
effect
unfortunately terrorism is a form of
crime but you can't stop it by using the
police or the military for example
nobody would consider fighting the
Italian mafia by bombing Naples that's
part of the strategy to fight is people
have to realize that this won't really
solve anything just create new problems
by producing new is recruits who are
bent on revenge
thank you thank you